à
[Musique]
soul cheuvreux ce que vous avez commencé
j'avais été anakin skywalker me bayle ce
nom ne signifie plus rien à une fille
jeune et puissant
tu as peur d'être moins fort que tarbes
bat
raison
quelqu'un m'explique mans
les jedi
il tue ce fait appeler nos mails qui
devient chaude dans cet ordre au sommet
de leur puissance ils ont laissé darcis
dieu créateur de nos clients des balayer
ces huitièmes
moi je suis
[Musique]
ce n'est pas que la conclusion de la
saga star wars mais également une
conclusion symbolique pour la chaîne
franchement qu'il était là au tout
premier trois théories qui était sur
personnage de ray sur star wars 7
nous avons quand même franchement bien
grandi bon ok le film fait énormément
débat et c'est tout à fait normal
entre déception et émotion il ait eu du
chemin et pour cette vidéo essayons
simplement de prendre un bon moment
ensemble et découvrons des vérités
cachées sur star wars neuf avec trois
théories que je vous propose
il faut que nous réagissions au retour
de palpatine le choix de le faire
revenir a fait énormément débat et je
suis premier à dire que c'est un terrain
glissant mais soit
essayons de justifier son retour déjà
comme l'affirment dominic monaghan dans
le film palpatine à employer d'anciennes
pratiques si tu sois ici le clonage ce
dernier fut tué par dark vador et c'est
un fait
ils l'affirment de lui-même quand il est
face à kai lorraine néanmoins comme dans
l'univers étendu son esprit reste actif
et ses plus fidèles partisans cherchent
à le faire revenir
et c'est là qu'un choix précis m'a fait
douter palpatine semble toujours dans
son corps dans l'épisode 9 mai ce
dernier est très amoché c'est pourquoi
il a l'air d'un légume
mais il y a une meilleure interprétation
effectivement allez savoir comment enfin
on se doute que c'est dû à sa formation
aux côtés de pelé guise l'esprit de
palpatine a survécu après sa mort dans
l'épisode 6 et connaissant jj abrams qui
aiment les références le rapprochement
est à faire avec l'univers étendu mais
surtout si palpatine cherche à retrouver
sa forme d'antan
ses partisans ont dû certainement
recréer son corps à partir de ces restes
et on en vient à sa descendance
palpatine ne retrouvera jamais sa
puissance d'antan et c'est un fait
il a été tué même la voix d'anakin le
dit et résonne à travers ray ramène l'
équilibre comme je lé fais le véritable
problème de star wars n'a fait que peu
de choses sont développées sur le
background du retour de l'empereur mais
nous sommes quand même face à palpatine
plus grands manipulateurs de la galaxie
est l'un des plus noirs seigneur sith
rappelez-vous de darth plagueis l'ancien
maître de palpatine qui pouvaient
manipuler la vie palpatine refait même
la référence à l'épisode 3 quand il
comptait son histoire anaky al bateen
n'a pas pu reproduire la même erreur que
son ancien maître qui l'avait trompée
c'est pourquoi je pense qu'il avait émis
l'option d'une possible mort il aurait
donc créer sa descendance propre à lui
pour avoir dans le futur un véritable
réceptacle pouvant contenir ses pouvoirs
du à son sens et sa ligne et sites ou
pas le corps avec le temps failli et
faibli
c'était un moyen pour sidious de rester
éternels malheureusement son fils s'est
fermé à tout ça par choix connaissant la
nature de son nom de famille et les
intentions de son père c'est mentionné
par ben il n'était rien par choix c'est
pourquoi aux yeux de palpatine son fils
n'était qu'un faible jusqu'au jour où
rennes acquis effectivement si sidious
avait la main sur sa petite fille dès le
début c'était donc une nouvelle chance
pour lui des levées et manipuler un
descendant de sa ligne et ce comme il
l'aurait souhaité mais rêve fut cachée
et ses dernières s'est développé dans la
force c'est l'histoire que l'on connaît
mal batin recherchant un réceptacle
puissance est donc tournée vers calais
lorraine avec le déguisement de snow
club n étant à skywalker l'intérêt pour
lui était grand jusqu'au jour où ce ne
soit pas le patine sentirait le conflit
chez calderon était toujours trop grand
à cause de la mort de son père c'est
pourquoi a plus le temps passe et plus
qu'à y lorraine ne devenait qu'un pion
une erreur de snacks et au final
maintenant que palpatine c'est que ray
est en vie cai lorraine devient aussi
utile que le général ex entre guillemets
ray est le réceptacle parfait pour
accueillir l'esprit de palpatine
elle a ses pouvoirs elle a son nom elle
a son sens on peut le souligner jusqu'au
moment où palpatine se rend compte que
la dyade peut lui rendre directement sa
véritable forme d'origine et du coup au
bar elle ne sert donc plus à rien et
cela révèle son véritable but mais ret a
dépassé palpatine en termes de puissance
et je pense qu'il ya une signification
derrière ceci par le biais d'une
descendance palpatine à l'occasion de
créer plus qu'un réceptacle identique à
ce qu'il était par le biais de la
grand-mère terai palpatine aurait pu
couple et ses pouvoirs avec une femme
puissante dans la
force non pas une skywalker karben était
le dernier skywalker c'est l'empereur
qu'ils l'affirment mais ray pourrait
être la fusion d'une palpatine et d'une
autre ligne et puissante dans la force
du permettant donc de surpasser
l'empereur comme elle le fit à la fin de
star wars 9
pour rester dans tout ce qui touche à
palpatine j'aimerais ramener une
problématique qui avaient été amenés
dans star wars 7
car voilà moi tout ce qui touche à la
cohérence d'un univers son développement
et cetera
c'est vraiment ce qui me passionne
george lucas ce imaginait apparemment à
la base que s'il devait y avoir une
troisième trilogie lempire renaîtrait de
ses cendres avec l'empereur et c'est au
final ce qu'il s'est passé
même si cela ne semblait pas forcément
prévu par disney via l'opus 7 et 8
néanmoins comme je vous l'affirmé dans
la première théorie palpatine et très
amoché et fut même tuer en quelque sorte
il cherche donc un nouveau réceptacle
pour se rebâtir et retrouver sa
puissance ainsi que celle de l' empire
ray et donc son réceptacle idéal mais
jusqu'à son âge adulte elle restera
caché sur jack ou et ne sera jamais
retrouvée et c'est là que quelque chose
de très intéressant intervient dans star
wars et nous savons que les
stormtroopers comme fines sont des
enfants kidnappés d un âge très jeune
pour être élevés comme des soldats du
premier ordre
alors outre le fait que cette technique
sert à promouvoir la peur et surtout
grossir les rangs et se pourrait qu'une
explication supplémentaire puisse
intégrer effectivement comme l'a
démontré la saga complète de star wars
des êtres exceptionnels sont cachés dans
la galaxie
nous avons en quelque sorte l'exemple
avec anakin découvert par kwh gones sur
tatouine même si l'origine d'anakin est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça mais bref
l'idée là anakin est un être tout à fait
exceptionnel l'élu et personne ne
connaissait son existence tout comme
l'udc qui fut cachée par obi wan et qui
au final sera la clé permettant de faire
revenir son père ainsi que l'espoir est
enfin nous avons de nouveau le cas avec
ray sur jack ou palpatine est un très
grand manipulateur et ce dernier a été
témoin deux fois par le passé de ce
phénomène
or au moment de star wars est ce dernier
et cherche à se reconstruire avec
de ses plus fidèles partisans se serait
pourquoi ce dernier par le biais du
premier ordre ferait kidnappé les
enfants afin de trouver de nouveaux un
être exceptionnel et s'en servir comme
réceptacle pouvant accueillir ses
pouvoirs et peut-être même chercher ray
directement car après tout sa naissance
et bost star war 6 néanmoins même si
palpatine cherche à retrouver sa
puissance d'antan comme le montre le
dénouement ultime de star wars 9
l'idée de se servir d'un nouveau pseudo
apprentis n'est pas à éloigner
exactement comme il le fit avec ben solo
et du coup les enfants qui étaient tout
à fait normaux servait juste à rejoindre
les rangs
cette idée pour moi accentuée également
par la bande dessinée de l'entraînement
de kayes lorraine
car dans cette bd totalement canon
cannon tout dépend de votre
prononciation snoeck qui est donc
sidious en quelque sorte affirme accueil
lorraine qui vient tout juste de
détruire le sanctuaire sur dagobah qu'il
souhaitait amener d'autres personnes et
cela révèle beaucoup de choses et
d'ailleurs j'aimerais faire un
rapprochement avec ce mandat lauriane
donc désolé je veux te voir un petit peu
spoil la série tout le monde commence à
connaître baby yoda et ce petit être est
vraiment très mystérieux il semble être
de la même espèce que yoda d'où le terme
baby yoda et possède des pouvoirs qui se
rapprochent de ceux de ré dans star wars
9 mais surtout ce petit être est
recherché activement par les restes de
l' empire qui sont encore loin de s'être
reformer et il est très facile de se
douter pourquoi il est recherché ce
dernier sait manipuler grandement la
force malgré sa jeunesse entre
guillemets et je serai prêt à dire que
ce bio da est l'une des raisons de
pourquoi l' empire puis finalement le
premier ordre se sont mis à enlever des
enfants valent batin connaissait son
adversaire yoda à l'époque il
connaissait sa puissance suite à star
wars 6 imaginez si palpatine avait
réussi à former ou intégré le corps de
ce petit être
surtout que l'intriguent demande à
laurianne se passe avant la naissance de
ré baby yoda serait le premier argument
de la recherche des enfants puissant
dans la force car après tout c'est une
thématique principale à mener dans cette
nouvelle trilogie
beaucoup d'utilisateurs de la force
existe et ne sont pas des jedi ou d
cit d'ailleurs ce mandat lauriane
pourrait avoir beaucoup plus de
rapprochement dans l'intrigué de star
wars 9 et même la nouvelle trilogie que
l'on pourrait le penser mais nous en
reparlerons dans une prochaine vidéo
dans tous les cas ray et peut-être même
baby yoda semble être tous les deux
beaucoup plus principaux que l'on
pouvait l'imaginer à la base
[Musique]
il me tardait de parler plus en
profondeur du cadre est vous le savez
tous ici c'est même le tout premier
trois théories de la chaîne
le personnage devrait m'obsédait de par
ses origines inconnues alors qu'elle
émanait une forte puissance
maintenant nous possédons les réponses à
tout ça elle est la dernière des jedi
une palpatine de sang et une skywalker
de coeur ok très bien mais maintenant il
se passe quoi car oui s'il ya bien une
chose dont j'aimerais traité c'est la
suite de ré et la conclusion proposé par
star wars 9
la symbolique autour de ré et je trouve
grandiose dans star wars 9 malgré les
soucis du film comme je vous l'affirmé
pour moi les jedi devait s'éteindre et
l'udc l'avait très bien expliqué dans le
huit
il n'était pas seulement tant pour les
sites d'en finir mais également les jedi
c'est pourquoi il fallait pour moi
absolument que ray kay lorraine et
palpatine meurent pour signer
définitivement toute trace de
développement lumineux ou obscurs et
personnellement c'est pourquoi j'ai bien
aimé l'idée de tous les sites sont en
moi et tous les jedi sont en moi nous
étions vraiment face aux ultimes êtres
vivants détenant savoir profond des arts
sith et jedi
bref comme vous l'avez vu à la fin de
star wars 9 ray est en possession d'un
sabre jaune qui pourrait d'ailleurs même
être un double sabre vu qu'il a été
conçu à la base sur son bâton mais de
nouveau nous sommes face aux conflits de
l'univers étendu et du canon apparemment
dans l'univers étendu le sabre jaune
signifierait une profonde envie de
détruire le côté obscur néanmoins ces
deux symbolique ne correspond pas pour
moi car d'accord ray s'autoproclame
skywalker au lieu de palpatine son
véritable nom donc qu'elle est bien du
côté lumineux etc
et c'est là que je m'interroge est-ce
qu'au final la couleur jaune du film ne
serait pas plutôt ici pour représenter
l'équilibré c'est-à-dire côté lumineux
de par le coeur de retz et côté obscur
de par son sang c'est la de la question
de l'avenir devient pertinente nous
sommes censés être face aux tous
derniers star wars de l'épopée skywalker
et j'insiste sur le fait que nous sommes
sur l'histoire des skywalker
c'était d'ailleurs le plan de
communication de disney nous sommes
véritablement sur la fin de la saga
principale et de la fin de l'histoire
des skywalker et rennes ne doit
absolument pas reproduire la même erreur
que l'udc avec son académie
auquel cas
cette nouvelle trilogie il n'aura
clairement servi à rien en quelque sorte
alors vous allez trouver que je vais
aller un peu loin mais même si la
symbolique est forte le fait que ray
possède son propre sabre laser signifie
du coup qu'elle est encore active et
qu'elle ne compte pas s'isoler comme
l'udc
d'après ce que le film nous a proposé et
c'est là que le risque est à prévoir
ray symbolise l' équilibre d'après cette
conclusion mais si cette dernière se met
à former des personnes elle pourrait
très bien reproduire la même erreur que
l'udc car même si ray a compris les
enjeux entre son nom et son éducation
ce n'est pas dit que des élèves et la
même sagesse imaginez si fine qui
semblent ressentir la force demande a
réduit enseigner ce que je veux dire
c est ce qu au final l'equilibre est
vraiment là due à la présence encore
actifs de ré avec son propre sabre
enfin d'ailleurs il faut que ray
répondent à la scène de luc avec yoda
dans le huitième opus c'est à dire
effacer les traces de l'apprentissage
jedi soit de brûler les anciens ouvrages
comme il était prévu afin d'éviter le
risque de créer de nouveaux jedi et donc
potentiellement faire revenir le côté
obscur également alors se pourrait-il
que finalement star wars 9 ne soit pas
vraiment la fin du voyage
je sais que vous allez me dire que
disney veut faire de l'argent mais dans
leurs campagnes marketing
la saga skywalker est normalement fini
et la nouvelle trilogie serait prévue
sur autre chose
la vidéo est maintenant terminée alors
je suis désolé on se retrouve quelques
jours plus tard tout simplement parce
que je voulais vous faire une intro un
peu spécial malheureusement par manque
de temps et de moyens elle n'a pas pu
aboutir
je voulais vraiment vous remercier pour
ces quatre dernières années où nous
avons pu échanger et faire plein de
théorie que ce soit sur star wars
surtout plein de sujets et du coup balle
la fin de cette nouvelle trilogie qu'on
avait commencé ensemble ce n'est pas la
fin de la chaîne ce n'est pas la fin des
trois théories on va continuer d'en
faire mais on est quand même un gros
chapitre qui se termine et surtout cette
année 2010 neuf qui n'a pas été une
année toujours facile de mon côté et je
pense qu'on ne reviendra peut-être dans
un bilan quelconque dans les prochains
jours
j'ai de l'ambition j'ai des projets et
on va tout faire pour que 2020 ne fasse
pas comme 2019
sur ce nous sommes le 31 je vous
souhaite à tous une merveilleuse année
et passer un très bon réveillon et puis
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
bleu un petit commentaire à me suivre
sur youtube twitter instagram et puis
bah écoute et on se retrouve pour 2020
avec plein de rêves et plein de théorie
que le liner soit à vue
[Musique]